USA Today is college worth it
Goldman Sachs says not so much college
is certainly an investment but is it
worth it maybe not according to new
research from Goldman Sachs the company
said in a research note published in
early December that the average return
on college is falling in 2010 students
could expect to break even within eight
years of finishing school since then
that has increased to nine years and if
this trend continues students who went
to college will know it will be ten
years I couldn't resist I'm sorry
it's just like USA TODAY's writing is
from eight to nine if this trend
continues I had to edit I'm sorry
students who start college in 2030
without scholarships or grants it said
may not see a return on investment until
age 37 recent graduates can relate to
the report mary-kate Bowman a 2010
graduate of a private college in upstate
New York who also graduated from
journalism and business graduate
programs at the University of Missouri
this year said my undergraduate
education was 200 thousand in total my
first job paid only 28 thousand that's a
large disparity think Goldman Sachs
calculated the economic return on
college education as the total all-in
cost of college net grants of the
scholarships and the wages foregone
during the four years of the study
versus a high school graduate over their
working life of course many students say
college is money well spent I think it's
worth it to grow as a person and there
are so many other experiences the
college teaches you said Vanderbilt
University senior Chris look who plans
to go into the consulting field after
paid fifty six thousand dollars a year
for tuition at Vanderbilt
it's just funny you guys I'm sorry
people that are ignorant about education
it's just the oxymoronic part of that
makes me to get tickled I can't resist
all right let's let's hit the education
topic one more time since USA Today has
helped us with this goldman sachs is
calculating the return on investment at
least somebody's thinking that there
ought to be an ROI that's a good pot
there ought to be an ROI they ought to
be alive here's the thing on there's
there's a rule in statistics and often
when a liberal is arguing with me they
bring the rule up and it's a valid rule
called causation or correlation does not
necessarily imply causation so because
college students incomes are higher we
correlate that with the fact that they
went to a college graduates incomes are
higher we correlate that and say that
the income was caused by the fact that
they went to college and the ruin stats
is you can't necessarily say the cause
of their higher income is their college
education well what would it be then
well it could be that the very things
that cause them in their character to go
to college in the first place and
complete college the ability to complete
something the ability to drive through
the lane and put the ball in the hoop
called grit
maybe grit is what caused their higher
income not college but maybe great lead
you to college because you want to be
smarter so maybe it's not necessarily
causation and correlation situation
they're really listen I'm all about
education all three of my kids went to
school told them we're gonna have them
shot if they didn't so they all four got
four-year degrees okay I mean we believe
in education around the Ramseys done
being dumb is really not a good idea
I mean learning stuff is a smart thing
but we have completely taken this
college thing and blown it up and in
this country and in this culture and
we've lost our ever loving minds I mean
this chick who gets two hundred thousand
dollars for undergraduate and goes and
gets a twenty eight thousand our job I
mean somewhere along the line you never
got a clue kiddo I mean what were you
study I mean you got a degree in
business and in journalism and your
first job is making twenty eight K you
know you each logistics majors are
coming out now
by chain people are coming out now
making fifty to sixty with an undergrad
only so maybe if you're going to study
something you ought to stop and freaking
think about what it's going to pay when
you get out of school there should be a
correlation to what you're studying that
would keep you from getting a degree in
miscellaneous stupid stuff got a PhD in
German polka history and then I can't
figure out why I can't get a job because
there are no jobs for doctorates in
German polka history that's just
ridiculous and but but the you know the
society owes me a dadgum living because
I'm highly educated and I'm a twit and
you know that's just ridiculous people
see what we have here is really not an
education problem really not a cost of
college problem what we have here is a
parenting problem some of you people are
raising twits and then you turn them
loose on the culture and act like
college ruined them no they were ruined
long before they got to college College
just expose that they were twits and the
fact that you go $300,000 in debt to get
a degree in women's studies and then
can't figure out that being a you know
full-time feminist is probably not a
career track you know it just doesn't
work out for you
and so and they can't figure out why you
can't make a living you know sorry if
you're going to study broadcasting you
ought to find out what radio people get
paid which I'll help you with that most
of them not much so I mean don't go
spend $400,000 getting a degree in
broadcasting so you can be a
sportscaster at the local high school
game and starve to death I mean
seriously
think about what you're going to do with
the degree and since most eighteen year
olds don't have that ability this is a
parenting thing you moms and dads need
to put your arm around that little child
of yours that looks like an adult
because their body is large but their
brain has not yet grown in fully and you
need to walk with them and scho no
stupid you can't do this I love you too
much to allow you to take this track
with your field of study and where
you're going to school to get your
degree that you can't afford
so maybe everyone can't afford to go to
a private college maybe everyone can't
afford to go to Harvard or Yale maybe
everyone can afford to drive a Bentley
and so what do you get you get a used to
pick up it's not a bad thing by the way
a lot of times the guy driving use
pickups got more brains than got around
in the Bentley so just think think so
here's the thing you want your children
to be successful yes education is
important in a field of study that is
applicable in the marketplace at a
school that is cheap enough that it will
ROI some time in this freaking century
that's thing one thing too is the
education is just part of the equation
teaching your kids grit how to play
through how to work hard how to work
hard how to bathe before they go to a
job interview how to smile when they go
to a job interview how to squeeze a hand
firmly but not ridiculously firm and
smile how to say thank you how does talk
to an employer about what they can bring
to the table instead of acting like a
parasite asking what the employer is
going to pay teach your children some
walking-around since now there's a
correlation that you can get that'll
cause success this is the Dave Ramsey
show you guys would be so rich so fast
and be able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others